yeah throw that in  hey guys my name's Sarah Stephens I'm at  pouring ribbons bar in Alphabet City and  I'm gonna show you how to make my  favorite drink Manhattan so we start off  this guy here half an ounce of gin zono  whoa wait we do that again half an ounce  of Manteca you can use just one type of  sweet vermouth I'm using two just adds  body and texture to the drink two ounces  of rye whiskey you can use ribbon if you  like sweeter drinks two dashes of  bitters then my favorite tool the  cracker got a cube of ice sort of a  messy  then stir it up for like maybe 20  seconds no good  get your gloss  zest of an orange and you just squeeze  it releases all the oils around the rim  off the stem and make it look all pretty  put it in that nice little spiral like  that and pop it in the glass now you've  got your perfect Manhattan my favorite  pot on that seam and then just I have to  get the fancy glass there it is and  that's how you